el gobernador Luis Fernando Camacho está
acusado en el caso golpe uno por haber
liderado las protestas sociales del año
2019 que han derivado en la renuncia del
expresidente Evo Morales y en la
posesión de un gobierno transitorio el
gobierno de Luis Arce considera que en
esos hechos Se ha producido un golpe de
estado y por eso está acusando a Luis
Fernando Camacho por ese hecho y él está
acusado concretamente de tres delitos
terrorismo sedición y conspiración al
respecto el gobernador que ha pasado su
primera noche en las celdas de la
policía de la paz no ha respondido a los
fiscales sin embargo ha emitido un
escrito que ha pedido que se introduzca
en el expediente en el que él señala que
se siente orgulloso de haber dirigido
las protestas del año 2019 porque ha
estado defendiendo la democracia y el
voto que según él estaba en riesgo por
lo tanto defiende lo que él considera
que fue una gesta social en Bolivia y no
un golpe de estado como señala el
gobierno de Luis arce y ahora hablemos
un poco de lo que ocurrió el miércoles
porque como lo hablábamos hubo daños en
la fiscalía en aeropuertos y también en
casas cuéntenos qué ha pasado desde ayer
en las últimas horas se ha elevado la
atención y la violencia en Santa Cruz
particularmente de hecho según los
reportes oficiales el 80% del edificio
de la fiscalía departamental ha sido
dañado por la quema que se ha producido
en la víspera también se reporta que 30
vehículos han sido calcinados y otras
instalaciones han sido quemadas por
ejemplo el ministro de Obras Públicas ha
reportado que su casa ha sido incendiada
por otro lado esta mañana las
principales carreteras del departamento
de Santa Cruz han amanecido bloqueadas
en protesta por la detención del
gobernador Luis Fernando Camacho